der kauf sei nicht
ganz wichtiger metaphysischer begriff
kausalität meint einfach erst mal
allgemein nur die verbindung von ursache
und wirkung also eine relation es dann
kausal wenn ein ereignis
die ursache von einem anderen ereignis
ist das ist qualität
was sind ursachen was sind wirkungen das
eine ganz spannende frage in der
philosophie manche sagen ursachen seien
dinge also zum beispiel substanzen
diese auffassung ist aber eine neue
debatte ihr zurückgedrängt worden
heutzutage vertritt man die auffassung
dass ursachen ihr ereignisse sind also
ursachen und wirkung sind ereignisse die
in der welt stattfinden
manche gehen soweit und sagen ursachen
wirkungen sind tatsachen oder sogar
situationen also eine bestimmte
situation bestimmten faktoren die
verursacht eine andere situation
kausalität erkennen ist nicht leicht in
der geschichte der philosophie gibt es
einen ganz bedeutenden philosophen mit
den namen david hume hat im achtzehnten
jahrhundert gelebt und david hume hat
die these vertreten dass wir kausalität
eigentlich gar nicht erkennen können was
wir erkennen könnt ist nicht der
notwendige übergang von einer ursache zu
einer bestimmten wirkung sondern immer
nur regula riten also immer wenn er ein
ereignis derart a einem ereignis derart
b vorher geht dann könnten wir von
kausalität sprechen das sind regula
riten aber wir können daraus nicht
erkennen aufgrund solche regularien dass
die ursache von b ist das also be auf
erfolgen muss wir haben bisher immer nur
die erfahrung gemacht dass wenn a war
dann auch ein ereignis des typs b folgte
aber eine notwendige verknüpfung können
auf diese empirische weise das induktive
weise eben nie objektiv rechtfertigen
die frage ob es der sanität gibt ist
durchaus umstritten
sicherlich kann man von kausalität
sinnvoll reden wenn wir uns im
lebensweltlichen kontext weg man nennt
das auch in der physik den mesokosmen
also den mittleren kosmos die mittlere
welt im gegensatz zur großen welt dass
es dem makrokosmos das sind also die
dimensionen der planeten der galaxien
des universums oder aber auch des
mikrokosmos das ist die dimension der
kleinsten teile der quanten im maison
kostenlos in unserer lebenswelt da gilt
mit sicherheit kausalität die frage ist
die ob es auch im mikrokosmos noch
kausalität gibt viele physiker sagen er
nicht wir haben es dort nur mit
wahrscheinlichkeit verhältnissen zu tun
etwa dann wenn ein atom zerfällt
radioaktiv zerfällt können wir nicht
mehr mit sicherheit angeben wann was
passieren wird so nur noch mit welcher
wahrscheinlichkeit zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt etwas passiert sein wird